Các thầy mình còn đợi ai không?
Xin phép trình bày báo cáo tổng hợp toàn bộ
Phần nghiên cứu của em về sử dụng mô hình sinh dữ liệu
Để sinh dữ liệu tấn công SQN Injection
Nhằm nâng cao phát hiện dựa trên hỏng máy
Thì là mục tiêu của em
Mục tiêu tổng quát là sinh
Lựa chọn các phương pháp sinh hoặc bổ sung
Dữ liệu SQN Injection có kiểm soát
Để hỗ trợ mô hình
để nâng cao chất lượng của mô hình học máy
thì sẽ có tổng cộng là có 5 bước
đầu tiên là em sẽ kiểm soát dữ liệu
thì là em sẽ cố gắng điều chỉnh dữ liệu
để nó phù hợp hơn với mô hình bài toán
tiếp theo là em sẽ đề xuất tổng cộng là 5 phương pháp
thì sẽ có 4 phương pháp là 4 mô hình
đầu tiên là mô hình SMOTE là mô hình nội sinh dữ liệu
dữ liệu mô hình gan cơ bản là mô hình sinh dữ liệu gan cơ bản mô hình CT gan và si quần gan thì
CT gan là cũng là phương pháp gan nhưng mà chuyên xử lý cho dữ liệu dạng bảng còn si quần gan là
chuyên xử lý cho mô hình dữ liệu rời rạc sau đó là em sau khi so sánh xong thì em cảm thấy là mô
hình si quần gan có thể học được các mối quan hệ và cấu trúc câu nên là em đề xuất các phương án
và em sẽ đánh giá tổng cộng cả 5 mô hình này trên cùng một đầu và dữ liệu chung
Tên đề tài của em là nghiên cứu mô hình GAN cho sinh dữ liệu tổng cộng XQN
nhằm nâng cao mô hình phát hiện dựa trên hộp máy
Đây là tên đề tài của em
Rồi bây giờ quay lại kia, thế này nó phải thể hiện được tên đề tài
Cho nên cái mục tiêu rủng quát là phải gắn với gan
Lúc trước trong tin nhắn của người của em
Thế là em phải đi với cái tên đề tài
Học dụng của em có giúp bây giờ thầy đề tài được rồi
Nhưng mà người khách biết, cái mục tiêu rủng quát em phải xem trong đề cương
Thứ mục tiêu trong đề cương mình biết là kiểu này, kiểu này nó lại bị lệch nhau
Em hiểu
Thầy Châu Ước
Cái của em Minh ấy
Tức là mục tiêu là dùng
nghiên cứu về gan
và gan sử dụng trong sinh dữ liệu
Để hỗ trợ nâng cao cái
sức lượng hộp máy luôn đúng không anh nhỉ
Đúng rồi
Thế thì thầy muốn là
Đấy là mục tiêu thủng quá
Thế còn đi vào phép chi tiết ấy
Thì mới đoàn là
Thứ nhất là
không phải kiểm soát dữ liệu
mà đây là tìm hiểu về dữ liệu
Đúng không
Đấy mình tìm hiểu về cái bài toán
Bài toán và dữ liệu
Cái đấy em hiểu nhé
Nhớ với liên quan bài toán và dữ liệu
Bài toán nó là cái gì, dữ liệu là cái gì, đặc trưng là gì vân vân
Dữ liệu nó chỉ là cái mục 1, không phải kiểm soát dữ liệu
Dữ liệu nó chỉ là một hình ảnh nhỏ thôi
Đúng chưa?
Sau đó là các phương pháp giải quyết nó
Theo thầy nói em là cái SMODE nó là baseline của các phương pháp cân bằng
Để dữ liệu làm cân bằng
Rồi đến nhóm các phương pháp khí văn gân
Nó mới tách ra
Nhóm gân đấy là nhóm trọng tâm của đoán
Và trong nhóm gân đấy thì có 2 nhóm
1 là nhóm sinh đặc trưng
Nhóm thứ 2 là sinh gân
Nhóm sinh đặc trưng chính là gân truyền thống
rồi WANIGAN, rồi CITIGAN
rồi bắt đầu đến SEQUENT ONE
là nhóm XINYA CHUỐI
XINYA CHUỐI THẬT luôn đấy
Được chưa?
Riêng cái phần đấy em đã chạy được
so sánh SEQUENT GAN, SO SÁNH CITIGAN
Đấy cũng đã làm phần lớn
mục đích của
của gì nhỉ?
của đồ án
cộng với cái phần kiểm tra toàn này nữa
để mình xem chất lượng nó như thế nào
Cái phần làm thêm xuất sắc chính là phần cải tiến này.
Đó chính là đoán nền cao của em.
Cái đấy phải nhớ về chỉnh sửa cho nó đúng theo đề phương nhé.
Đầu tiên là nguồn dữ liệu.
Đây là dữ liệu về SQL index được tải nhiều nhất trên Kaggle
và có rất nhiều bài báo có đề cập tới tài liệu này nên em sử dụng làm đại diện đặc trưng ạ
thì tổng dữ liệu thì sẽ có hơn 30.000 ạ
thì sau khi được tiền xử lý là loại bỏ các cái dữ liệu trùng lập
thì xuống còn cũng 30.800 ạ
trong đó thì các chuỗi bình thường thì 19.000 ạ
chuỗi đắn công là 11.000 ạ
Nhược điểm của các phương pháp truyền thống là người ta sẽ đưa thẳng toàn bộ dữ liệu của SQL vào mà không phân chia gì
Nên là khi mà sinh ra dữ liệu thì một câu lệnh có thể có nhiều đặc tính của nhiều dạng tầm công khác nhau
Thế nên là thường là dữ liệu sinh ra là dữ liệu nhiễu và không có giá trị về mặt thực tế
Thế nên là em sẽ tiến hành là sẽ chia nhỏ ra làm các thành phần riêng để có thể tập trung vào các đặc trưng của từng phương pháp
Thì trong này thì em sẽ chia ra làm 4 họ tấn công
Thì sẽ có là tấn công kiểu Poland, Union, Tham và Ireland
Thì trong này là có các cơ chế
Thì trong này có dấu hiệu thường gặp của Boland là trong cái câu toán toán tử đấy sẽ có các cái có
n o các phép so sánh dùng nháy common Union thì sẽ có các từ ngữ nhảy Union select danh sách cột
hoặc là null Time Bay thì sẽ có các hàm tạo độ chế thì ở trong này thì sẽ từng từng database thì nó
thì nó sẽ có những hàm tham bấy khác nhau ạ và Aaron thì là sẽ có hàm cố tình gây ra lỗi ạ
Cái chút này thầy có ghi cho em rồi nhưng em chưa sửa
Nghĩa là nó đã kể ra trong trình bày trong văn đề phần thông tin này luôn là có thêm phần thông tin
Ví dụ
Đấy em luôn cho luôn cái chuỗi ví dụ ở đây
Thì trình bày của thầy thì em thấy là rõ rất nhiều
Cả trong báo cáo cũng trong slides
Vâng ạ
Đúng chưa
Thì em gắn gọn thôi không cần dài
Vâng
Thì đây là quy trình tiền xử lý rượu của em ạ
Thì là đầu tiên là em sẽ có một bộ dữ liệu
Thì bộ dữ liệu này chỉ đơn giản là có hai cột
Một cột payload và một cột được đánh nhán
Tiếp theo là em sẽ chuẩn hóa
Thì là em sẽ cố gắng chuyển tất cả các chữ kiểu dấu nháy
Chữ hoa, chữ thường và khoảng trắng
Khoảng trắng dài
Thì sẽ chuyển hết về một khoảng trắng
Và chữ hoa, chữ thường thì chuyển hết về chữ thường
Nghĩa là đồng bộ hóa lại để hạn chế việc là
sinh giặc học quá nhiều token, học quá nhiều các đặc trưng
si quần gan là học quá nhiều đặc trưng nên là trước đây em làm
vấn đề mà em gặp phải là quá nhiều đặc tính nó hồi học
nên là em làm thế này để hạ thấp các đặc tính xuống
tiếp theo
thầy trước này nhé, xác ngược thầy chung thầy chủ tịch thôi
nhưng mà mình nói như thế này là theo thầy trên website
nên chỉ có mỗi 1 cái shadow này
Em gạch đầu dòng có thể có 1 số lý do tại sao tiền sử dụng như em nói
Đúng không? Đấy nó rất hợp chút nào thì mình cần tiền sử dụng
Đúng không? Chứ em nói bao giờ gần như mọi người chắc không vào tay được
Thế nên mình vừa nói thì phải có vừa 1 số gạch đầu dòng trên slide đó
Em đặt thầy vậy là em nên đưa ra ví dụ hay em cũng chỉ giải thích
Không, trước này là 1 ví dụ, trước này là gạch 1 số đầu dòng là lý do tại sao
để sử dụng vật làm cái gì. Sau đó em mô tả quy trình này.
Chứ kể cái pseudo nó quá bé nên nó tăng cái text lên.
Ở đây mình không thể nhìn được cái text nhỏ nhỏ.
Tiếp theo là tạo fingerprint.
Ở đây thay vì trong các câu lệnh sẽ có những số như 1, 2, 3 hoặc là 99.
thì nếu như để số riêng như thế thì là mô hình nó sẽ học ví dụ như có 99 con số cùng một chức năng
nghĩa là chỉ có giá trị số thì mô hình sẽ phải học tận 99 đặc tính
thay vì thế là em sẽ chuyển hóa tất cả những giá trị ký tự dạng số này thành một chuỗi là ví dụ như 5
để mã hóa lại hoặc là character để mã hóa lại để tập trung dữ liệu hơn
Nghĩa là những cái dữ liệu mà có chung chức năng thì em sẽ em hóa lại ở chung ạ.
Mình nhớ rất là hẻm thẻ em có 15 phần trình bày.
Hôm tới bảo hỏi 8 thế.
Nếu em cứ lăm man này thì em sẽ không đi vào chính được.
Đây là tập để không báo cáo luôn đấy.
Cảm ơn.
Giờ em cũng mới nhận ra.
Em hãy chú ý kỹ hơn.
Tiếp theo là cuối cùng là em sẽ phân loại ra 4 họp SQL dựa trên các đặc tính mà em có nói ở slide trước ạ.
Thông qua một thư viện gọi là SQL Power.
trong này sẽ có 2 nhánh sinh dữ liệu
thì là đầu tiên là trong này sẽ có nhánh sinh dạng dữ liệu cấu trúc
nghĩa là dạng kiểu token
còn những dạng mà chỉ cần dạng bình thường
nghĩa là dữ liệu dạng chỉ có 2 cột là cột payload và cột đánh nhãn
thì em sẽ sinh ra làm 2 nhánh để phục vụ cho 2 mục tiêu riêng
Đây là tổng quan về 5 phương pháp của em
Thì đầu tiên là em sẽ đến với thuật toán của SMOD
Thì là em dựa trên bài báo vào năm 2002
Về bài báo liên quan đến nội sinh gốc
Bài báo gốc về thuật toán
Thì đây là cấu trúc
Thì cấu trúc của nó là nó sẽ cố gắng nội sinh
Để tìm ra được giá trị gần nhất
Tìm ra được giá trị gần nhất
phù hợp và từ đó là nó sẽ sinh ra dữ liệu
sinh ra dữ liệu mà có cái độ tương đồng gần nhất
thì trong này sẽ có các công thức
anh muốn hỏi là
em về nhà tập, có 15 chừng 7
tập cho nó chuẩn những cái gì mà nó không phải trọng tâm của mày
để có định sự đi xa
tiếp theo là GAN thì là dựa trên bài báo 2014 của Godfrey
Thì bài báo này cũng là nền tảng của mô hình GAN
Thì đây cũng là lưu đồ thật toán
Thì nó khá là cơ bản
Sẽ tạo ra một generator và tạo ra một discriminator và cố gắng đối kháng
Để có thể tự tiện 2 mỗi 2 thành phần đấy tự tiện hóa để có thể sinh ra dữ liệu tốt hơn
Còn mô hình CTGAN
Mô hình CT GAN là giải quyết bài toán của mô hình GAN là sẽ thay thế hàm mất mát
Bởi vì là mô hình GAN là sẽ rất cần
CT GAN là Contribusal Tabular GAN
Em nhậm Conditional Tabular GAN
Trong mô hình này thì mô hình sẽ không hiểu được ý nghĩa của một chuỗi
Vì vậy là sẽ yêu cầu là cần phải phân tích một chuỗi để ra làm rất nhiều các đặc tính nhỏ hơn
Và từ đó là sẽ học các đặc tính đấy
Quay lại slide trước
Bây giờ em thay thêm một cái hình vẽ khung Facebook của Dan nó dễ hiểu hơn cái này
Đâu là cuối giờ, đâu là cuối đêm, giữ mình vẽ ra
Em đưa thầy phần giải thích của em có cần phải cải thiện
Hay là hỏi em phải phóng thói thì người ta hãy tự tươi dây nhìn với sơ đồ em
thì đọc hỏi nó là cái gì đấy.
Còn người ta đã quen với vật ngang nữa rồi thì mình nên theo chủ ngang.
Chạy từ trái sang phải.
Bây giờ em tự sợ trên mạng mình một cái sơ đồ gàn bao giờ đã vẽ là chạy trái sang phải
thì chạy xuống dưới chiếc của em.
Gàn mô đồ. Đúng chưa?
Ít nhất là một vài cái em thấy nó chạy từ trái sang phải.
Đúng không?
Mình đừng có phát minh ra một cái mới gì cho nó khó hình dung.
Chọn cái tiêu biểu nhất để thầy hay dùng.
Được chưa anh? Rồi, tiếp theo là Sequel Gantt
Sequel Gantt, anh sẽ chú ý để vẽ kỹ hơn
Một người chú ý giúp mình nghĩ là các em nếu dùng AI sinh slide thì phải chú ý
Nó còn sinh bé xíu, tức là mình phải cố gắng nhìn và điều chỉnh
Ở nhà anh để máy tính lên lớp cách cao khoảng 10-15m xem mình có thể nhìn được không
Thì đây là các vấn đề em quan sát ở gan cơ sở
Thì đây là em nêu ra các vấn đề mà em nhận thấy mô hình si quần gan gặp phải
Thì đầu tiên là cần phải tokenize theo ký tự
bởi vì là các ký tự mà có chung cái mục đích và có chung chức năng
thì nếu như mà không tokenize hóa lại
thì nó sẽ sinh ra rất nhiều các cái đặc tính
mặc dù là nó không giải quyết vấn đề gì ạ
tiếp theo là trong bài toán mà tác giả Yu đưa ra
thì độ dài tối đa là 20 ạ
thì là đối với những payload mà nó quá dài
thì nó sẽ bị cắt đi rất nhiều thành phần khá quan trọng ạ
tiếp theo là reward thì chỉ đến từ discriminator
Thì nghĩa là trong này Discriminator chỉ có khả năng nhận biết xem là
Theo thầy như thế này, tức là em sẽ trình bày như thế này
Tức là em sẽ trình bày sức khỏe gan sau
Và em sẽ trình bày luôn phần thử nghiệm
Thử nghiệm giữa các hộ gan với nhau
Và với SMOTE
Sau đó em sẽ đi sang phần nhận xét về vấn đề của nó và các cải tiến
Anh chú ý cho đấy
Rồi, em xin hãy trình bày tiếp nốt slide này ạ
Thì Reward của Digital Editor chỉ có khả năng nhận biết xem là dữ liệu có phải dữ liệu tạo sinh hay không
Chứ không có khả năng nhận biết là có phải mẫu SQL thực tế hay không
Và bất cân bằng nghiêm trọng thì ở đây là khi mà dữ liệu càng ngày càng ít đi ạ
Thì dữ liệu nó sẽ chỉ cố gắng sinh ra những dữ liệu mà nó có khả năng đạt điểm cao nhất ạ
Thế nên là nó sẽ lập điệp lại một cấu trúc chung ạ
Và tường lửa thực tế thì nó sẽ bị nhận nhầm
Nghĩa là nó sẽ bị nhận nhầm nhoi thành tấn công ạ
Đây là 5 vấn đề mà em đã gặp phải trong lúc triển khai thử nghiệm ạ
Thì đấy em sẽ đề xuất là 4 phương án cải tiến để xử lý cho các vấn đề trên ạ
Thì đầu tiên là như em nói là có tokenize SQL ạ
những cái ký tự mà có chung cái ý nghĩa thì sẽ được tokenize hóa lại ạ
tiếp theo là em sẽ tăng pre-chain lên ạ
bởi vì là discriminator là khá là mạnh
nên là em sẽ cố gắng tăng cái generator pre-chain lên
một con số cao hơn là 120
em sẽ so sánh giữa 120 là của tác giả và 160 là của em ạ
của tác giả là chỉ có 120 nên là khi em làm là vẫn bị cô lao tiếp theo là em sẽ tăng độ dài thì
là tăng từ 20 lên 160 độ dài của trách tờ thì là độ dài độ dài Vâng vâng độ dài của chuỗi đầu vào
Thì ở 20 thì mô hình sẽ chỉ học từng câu nhưng nếu mà tăng lên 1.600 là mô hình sẽ học đến có thể là từng ký tự trong câu
Và cuối cùng là reward cấu trúc thì thay vì để 100% là discriminator thì em sẽ lấy thêm 0.3 đánh giá đến từ SQL PAR
để có thể cố gắng học được cả cấu trúc của SQL nữa
Thì đấy là 4 phần cập nhật mà em áp dụng vào
Đây là mô hình của em được chia làm 5 giai đoạn
Thì đầu tiên giai đoạn đầu vào là sẽ chạy 4 mô hình cơ bản
không em không không được em cái này em cắt từ bên luận án bài Word của em xa em
thì đầu tiên là khảo sát ban đầu ạ để xem là vấn đề thực tế gặp phải của các mô hình sinh
tính dữ liệu khi giải quyết bài toán SQL injection
Sau đó là em sẽ chọn các tỷ lệ và chọn dạng dữ liệu
Đầu nghĩa là em sẽ phân tích xem là liệu biến đổi ở phần dữ liệu nó có tác dụng không
và biến đổi ở các
cái tỷ lệ thông số chạy thì nó có tác dụng không ạ tiếp theo
là khi đó là em sẽ đề xuất các 8 phương án để có thể thay thế nâng cấp của mô hình sinh quần gan ạ
thì như ở trong sai trước ạ em có đề xuất là 4 cái hướng xử lý ạ thì em sẽ cho chạy thì là kết hợp
kết hợp 4 cái phương án đấy
thì nó sẽ để ra là 8 kịch bản
thì có kịch bản sẽ là không phương án
nâng cấp nào và sẽ có kịch bản là chỉ 2 phương án nâng cấp
thì tổng cộng là 8 phương án nâng cấp để xem là đâu là
mô hình có độ ổn định cao nhất
cuối cùng là em sẽ chạy đánh giá đầy đủ
khi này là em sẽ chạy với cấu hình tối đa
như khi này là sẽ chạy full Epoch
để đảm bảo là tất cả mô hình đều có chung
chất lượng
và cuối cùng là em sẽ đưa vào trong mô hình tường lửa
để đánh giá kết quả thực tế
thì kết quả của giai đoạn 1
thì là ở đây
thì là mô hình smooth
và 3 mô hình đầu tiên
thì là họ có kết quả rất là tốt
nhưng mà lại là
có bị trùng lặp
khá là cao, trong đó thì mô hình
sequence găng cơ sở thì tuy là
thông số lại xấu hơn
nhưng mà độ trùng lặp thì nó
chỉ rơi khoảng 19,4%
Dạ, nghĩa là bị trùng cấu trúc ạ, cấu trúc của một câu SQL nó bị trùng khớp luôn ạ, nó chỉ đơn giản là thay thế các cái thông số thôi ạ.
Vâng ạ, bản chất chỉ có một cấu trúc riêng ạ.
Vâng, thì khi đấy là em nhận ra là tuy là SQLGAN là có điểm cấu trúc nó thấp hơn và độ độc nhất cũng sẽ thấp nhưng mà nó không bị trùng dữ liệu đầu vào.
Thế nên là em sẽ cố gắng để nâng cấp mô hình SQL Ga lên
Ở giai đoạn 2 thì em sẽ chia ra làm 4 dạng family
Và có 8 kịch bản như em có đề xuất ở trên
Phần này em bị thiếu, em không quên mất công việc
thì đây là từ A đến F thì nó sẽ là các kịch bản để em sử dụng để thay thế đấy
kịch bản không thay đổi gì hả kịch bản?
dạ
không thay đổi là A
phần này em bị thiếu, em xin phép em mở vào Facebook của em đi
phần này em không để ý, em đã không đưa vào
thì đây ạ, tổng cộng là 6 kịch bản ạ
Nghĩa là khi mà chọn dữ liệu mất cân bằng
Nghĩa là em sẽ
Nghĩa là ví dụ như em sẽ có 3.000 dữ liệu
Em sẽ chỉ lấy 1.000 dữ liệu
Để có thể mô tả được về việc mất cân bằng dữ liệu
Thì trong đó em sẽ có tổng cộng là 6 phương án chọn
Thì đầu tiên là em sẽ chọn theo thứ tự
Độ dài
Vâng ạ
Thì sẽ có tổng cộng là
Thì A và B sẽ chọn theo độ dài
thì A sẽ là chọn ưu tiên dài nhất
và B là ưu tiên ngắn nhất
C là ưu tiên các cái chuỗi
mà nằm ở trong
phần phân vị
nghĩa là những cái chuỗi mà có độ khổ biến cao
tiếp theo là D là em sẽ
chọn ở trong khoảng phân vị
nghĩa là em sẽ bỏ đi
25% đầu và
75% sau sẽ chỉ tập trung vào
những cái phần dữ liệu mà có mật độ
cao nhất. Tiếp theo là em sẽ lấy
ngẫu nhiên và con số ngẫu nhiên của em
ở đây em lấy là 88
Và cái cuối cũng là em sẽ lấy theo độ đa dạng
Nghĩa là
Em sẽ tập trung vào
Em sẽ tập trung để lấy
Có thể lấy nhiều nhất các cái đặc tính nhất có thể
Thì đây là tổng cộng là 6 hướng
Mà em đề xuất
Em sẽ chú ý hơn
Bổ sung
Thì đây ạ
Thì kết quả của giai đoạn
Thì đây là kết quả của giai đoạn 2A
Thì là kịch bản
Kịch bản E và D
ED và B là 3 kịch bản
mà có được
thứ hạng 1 hoặc 2
cao nhất ạ
nên em sẽ chọn lấy các 3 kịch bản này ạ
đây là bảng xếp hạng ạ
tiếp theo là đến giai đoạn 2B
thì em sẽ
ở đây em sẽ có tổng cộng là 8 kịch bản
thì ở đây ạ
thì đầu tiên là mã V1
thì sẽ là của
tác giả luôn ạ, không thay thế ạ
thì V2 thì em sẽ tăng
độ dài chuỗi đơn vị tối đa lên
và phần còn lại thì vẫn giữ nguyên
và tương tự với các cái
đặc tính đấy nó là 4 cái hướng
mà em đề xuất
em đang
em chuyển từ
Word sang
đây là
một kịch bản mà có
các cái giá trị cao nhất
ví dụ như của Boland
thì là sẽ có kịch bản D
ở cái phần hàn 2A
Và kịch bản V8 là những kịch bản mà có top những cái giá thông số tốt nhất
Thông số tốt nhất là vẫn là như thế, đầu tiên là dữ liệu sẽ phải độc nhất
Tiếp theo là phải có cấu trúc không bị trùng lập với các cấu trúc ban đầu
Có độ độc nhất riêng và phần quan trọng nhất là phải có cấu trúc SQL
Theo thầy nghĩ là con số cụ thể giống như ở giai đoạn 1, 100% trùng bắp, 19% trùng bắp.
Thầy thì khi mà em làm như thế thì nó sẽ có rất nhiều bảng bởi vì là như ở trong này là của em đã có tận 80 kịch bản.
Thì là em không biết là có nên đưa hẳn toàn bộ thông số vào hay là em nên chỉ tập trung vào những cái mà em lựa chọn nữa.
Nó vẫn khá là nhiều.
Trước mắt em chỉ phải đầy đủ hết đã, sau đó người ta quyết định chọn cái nào.
Vâng, em sẽ điều chỉnh lại.
Trên này có tổng cộng 11 kịch bản.
Do kịch bản V8 thắng ở mọi kịch bản nên nó bị mất đi 1 kịch bản.
Bởi vì nó bị trùng nhau.
Nhưng mà tổng cộng là ở đây em có 11 kịch bản là em sẽ đề xuất để nâng cấp đưa vào trong mô hình si quần gan để chạy thử
Thì đây là kết quả của giai đoạn 3
Thì khi ở đây em sẽ chỉ tập trung chạy mô hình si quần gan với các nâng cấp của em
Thì ở đây là cấu trúc V8 thì sẽ có thông số tốt nhất
Thì độ độc nhất rất là cao
Và học được cấu trúc là tỷ lệ đến gần 85%
Tiếp theo sau là 3 mô hình còn lại
Thì đến cuối cùng là giai đoạn cuối là em sẽ chạy
Em sẽ chạy toàn bộ
Thì đây là thông số
Thì ở đây là em sẽ chỉ tập trung vào 3 tỷ lệ
Là 1 trên 100, 1 trên 200 và 1 trên 500
Đây em đang bị đưa thiếu khá nhiều thông tin
Thì em này xin phép là để buổi sau em sẽ bổ sung kỹ hơn
Vì
nói ra hơi bị dài
tiếp theo là
em sẽ đưa toàn bộ tất cả dữ liệu
được sinh ra từ các kịch bản
trên và đưa qua
từng lửa
thì là ở mô hình si quần gan cải tiến
của em ạ, thì tỷ lệ
bị chặn là nó sẽ
bị chặn
xe này cũng bị đưa
xe này cũng bị đưa thiếu
nhưng mà ý em là
trong mô hình si quần gan thì là
là tỷ lệ mà vừa bị không bị chặn và vẫn có cấu trúc ạ thì nó nhân đôi với nhau ạ thì nó sẽ có
thông số là cao nhất ạ còn các mô hình còn lại thì là hầu hết là do bị nó được vượt qua từng lửa là
do là nó sinh ra dữ liệu nhiếu ạ đấy thì cái chỗ đấy em để mấy người phân tích nhiều ở đây thì
Vâng, em bị đưa thiếu, em sẽ chú ý hơn.
Em nhớ cái này giống như của anh Nam, mình đưa lên cái gì nó phải hỗ trợ ra cái quan điểm của mình.
Phần trình bày của em đến đây kết thúc ạ.
Em vẫn muốn em có một ví dụ về kết quả thực tế của em.
Ví dụ về kết quả thực tế của em.
Ví dụ một cái chuỗi như thế này với cơ sở sinh gan.
Một cái chuỗi như thế này.
Ngoài các số liệu thống kê này thì giá trị của sườn gan là nó sinh ra chuỗi.
Chuỗi là người ta nhìn được.
Đúng không?
Vâng, xin cho em là em kết thúc bài trình bày của em và em sẽ cố gắng chỉnh sửa để có thể đưa ra bản size tốt hơn ạ.
Thầy nghĩ là những cái nó coi như là nó ngắn bọn thôi nhưng mà nó toát lên được cái mình làm cái gì và kết quả đạt được cái gì.
Vâng.
Đúng không?
Đúng ạ.
Thế hướng này cũng hay, quan trọng là có thể là cái kết quả sinh ra có thể nó chưa chua nhất, chưa tốt nhưng mà nó có cái hướng phát triển.
Để ví dụ các cơ quan khác thì chỉ xin các chức luôn
Cái này nó xin môn ra nữa
Xin môn ra
Xin ra rồi
Cái này là bạn xin xong đây
Nên là có thể giúp anh thấy
Sai trước em là em có đưa ví dụ không truyền đoạn
Và do là em nghĩ là nó
Em lại cho là nó không cần tiên
Em không đưa vào hàng sai
Cái này mới bị tiến rất là cao
Nếu mà em làm thành công
Thì em có thể đối với là
Là một cái côn